president Jarvis enero says the
situation is under control he sent in
the army and the rainy season has
arrived Brazil he says will solve its
own problems we'll look after the amazon
north vamos Udo schedules that willing
together we'll find a solution to these
fires and give satisfaction to the rest
of the world and people who think like
mr. McCaul should think two or three
times before wanting to get out of a
complicated situation like he finds
himself with an enormous rejection rate
in his country and wanting to damages
after a meeting in Brasilia with Amazon
state governors paulson ro even
suggested there should be more
development in the amazon region hours
later a congressional committee approved
an amendment to allow commercial
agriculture on indigenous reservations
something that is currently prohibited
we're winning this war with the support
of you all to show what the amazon
region is to show its potential and the
benefits it can bring to all including
our brothers the indians
Bolson ro has the support of the US
president with whom he has a close
relationship and a shared love of
tweeting
reaction in Brazil to their president's
handling of the crisis has been mixed no
one can live completely alone no one
grows alone any hope is always welcomed
as long as it's well intended aid cannot
be linked to any kind of submission to
foreign countries Brazil must have
autonomy over the Amazon we cannot
accept this internationalization of the
Amazon any further development of the
Amazon will be met with strong
opposition from around the world however
it's the indigenous communities who live
in the forest those with the most to
lose
who will react the strongest for the
people who live here in the Amazon
region this is normal natural they burn
and they will burn again next year
because they believe with the backing of
their political leaders this is the best
way to develop this land also Nara
believes this is Brazil's land to
develop and resents foreign interference
but the international community feels it
can't simply watch as this so called
lungs of the earth burn then will shrine
there out Hazira
Porto Vale northwestern Brazil